le courage d'aider de soutenir au péril
souvent de l'ordre mais grâce leur soit
rendue les policiers français
les gendarmes français qui ont commis
aux ordres de leurs supérieurs en
mettant en oeuvre la rafle du vel d'hiv
et d'autres races encore havrais et
ailleurs sont les ancêtres de ceux qui
aujourd'hui avec le même zèle tracé
midrand les sans-papiers débouté des
droits humains ces êtres vivants essaye
de survivre dans le dénuement seul ou en
famille colombe à la demande de l'état à
en accueillir une soixantaine dans les
prochains jours la municipalité leur
apportera vous prête aussi le en lien
avec les associations de la ville
rappelons nous que le parlement il ya
peu de temps à l'éteindre et un délit de
solidarité s'est fait battre au noyage
mais bien la réalité
finalement remise en cause dans le
conseil constitutionnel qui a consacré
la valeur constitutionnelle
de la fraternité un des trois piliers de
notre devise républicaine au site et
qu'aussitôt contourner par la loi à siné
l'immigration de 718 2010 rick est venu
grossir la loi initial je me suis permis
sait-on de dégression sur les politiques
qui nous est si proche et qui demeurent
souvent cachés et un visibiliser car je
suis hyper sonic l'heureuse les ressorts
qui permet la rafle du vel d'hiv il ya
soixante dix huit ans sont toujours en
oeuvre dans nos sociétés contemporaines
en france et au delà
d'où notre nécessaire vigilance pour te
lorsque nous créions plus jamais ça ne
nous considérions temps des vigiles
attaquent habiletés des acteurs de la
solidarité et que ce prix soit celui de
l'espoir envers celles et ceux qui n'ont
pas la même couleur de peau quand même
langue la même religion etc ont ensemble
dans une notion de race qui n'a pas lieu
d'être
le souvenir de la barbe de l'ennemi
c'est aussi cela
[Applaudissements]